jean marie bigard est avec nous voilà la
patte de jean marie jean marie nos maris
de lola a commencé avec ses collègues
chez paco boy quotidien tuchel qui ne
meurent jamais et bah écoutez on fait un
bon début d'émission
merci jean marie jane white ap un petit
blabla pour démarrer comme ça si c'est
une jeune femme qui fait ses causes
justes émission familiale et je t'aime
l'ex foncia texte
[Applaudissements]
shanghai 30
il dit je pense qu'à lui dans le sindh
jeune femme qui fait ses courses elle
achète une bonne âme c'est un poireau
rien de vulgaire là dedans l'instance à
un kiwi une petite pizzetti n'a la
cuisine et pour une personne
elle arrive à la caisse le caissier il
lui sourit pas ses articles ce truc puis
la regarde que c'est dieu vous êtes
salah a dit oui c'est vrai je suis seul
mais comment vous avez deviné on va et
disent assez facile vous est moche c'est
un plongeur wallace et bouteilles et
tout est dit m toi de profondeur et un
mec qui arrive sa hauteur qui lui n'a
rien pas de bouteille et tous les justes
en maillot de bain est un pur sucre que
ça en très haute estime herbe
je voulais être tranquille faire de la
plongée bon si je vais descendre le
début et descend à 20 mètres il a joué
tranquille et ça va mettre dix secondes
lui donne le mec il arrive à sa hauteur
fait chier je suis là et sa troupe met
dix secondes à bâle qu'il arrive et
prend son ardoise bon joueur avec le
crayon qui écrit sous l'eau et oui mais
que faites-vous à 30 mètres de
profondeur sans équipement est là le mec
il lui arrache lardoise des mains est
une marque je me noie konan bédié à sa
femme je te fais bien l'amour ce soir
attend donc à laisser médicale c'est là
je ferais bien le mot social dit ben non
c'est ton mal parce que ce soit mangé
des pertes blanc c'est pas comme ça il
m'avait dit c'est pas grave moi j'ai dit
diabète on va faire des meringues
[Applaudissements]
merci
par exemple ces paysans rivière du salon
de l'agriculture il a ramené des
préservatifs parfumés
ouais sa famille l'a tous vanille
chocolat cacahuètes il doit faire un jeu
je vais éteindre la lumière pour pas que
tu vois la couleur je m'étais moins
inventif et tu devras deviner le goût la
coquette et la lumière du baisse son
froc sa femme et attrapes l'habite a des
points forts et dit attends je n'ai pas
mis encore
aller mais qu'il est dans un
compartiment se retrouve seul en face
d'une dame très élégante très joli cas
une jupe un petit peu courte dans la
trame n'est pas peur tu vas voir c'est
une vie cas de la classe elle est
décomplexé complètement
la preuve elle croise un décroise ses
jambes
plusieurs fois maman le mec peut pas et
peut pas ne pas voir qu'elle n'a pas de
culotte toi il est un peu étonné un
moment là la jeune femme a lui dit est
belle hein elle vous plaît alors qu'il
est tétanisé oui absolument me fâche un
petit peu ému il y a jamais je vous êtes
un gentleman
regardez ce que je vais vous faire les
cartes les jambes l'hôte il a les yeux
rivés sur la sage subi net et dire
regardez bien elle va vous faire un clin
d'oeil ça et là il voit la choupinette
de dames qui se tordent potash a fait un
clin d'oeil wa10 est incroyable c'est
faire de tri unis oui regardez par
exemple regardez bien maintenant elle va
vous faire un bisou gare dispense et
voit les choupinette buvait presque avec
le bruit tu sais bien croyez que vous
êtes gentils venez vous asseoir à côté
de moi plus près car il se pas prier ce
même tout près c'est vrai les îles
acquis duré 20 minutes
au finish chéri mais si vous me lâche y
est ici bien ça venait d'y aller que
vous êtes gentille si vous voulez vous
pouvez me mettre deux doigts non ne me
dit pas quels ces sifflets
[Applaudissements]
ceci dit docteur j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde me niort en fait c'est un
peu comme si je n'existais pas élevé des
personnes suivantes y est allé et boy
c'est lui qui va amsterdam et il veut
voir les filles derrière les vitrines
ouais ses spécialités très belle fille d
maillot fluo et tous y tapas lavit
d'ananas et 10 et combien elle vit à 10
et 200 euros et 10 e
c'est cher dit oui mais c'est du double
vitrage
[Applaudissements]